[موسيقى]
لذا
[تصفيق]
تغيرت استطلاعات الرأي بين الأشخاص الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 30 عامًا
بشكل كبير على مدار العامين
الماضيين والآن أصبحت الأغلبية تؤيد
التخلص من الملكية ، فالملكية
تعارض بشدة روح العصر إذا
كنت تحب ذلك  أنا أيضًا أهلاً للصحة العقلية ،
كل هذه القضايا المتنوعة التي
يتم الحديث عنها كثيرًا ،
ونرى كل هذه الفضائح نوعًا ما
تضع نفسها في مواجهة تلك الأسباب
، وأعتقد أن الناس على
نحو متزايد سيرون أن الأمر قد انتهى
تمامًا  تواصل مع أه مع بقية
العالم وفيما يتعلق بحملتنا ، فإن
مهمتنا الكبيرة هي الاستمرار في
تسليط الضوء على القضايا
وإظهار الناس أن هذا ليس
النظام الملكي الذي كنت تعتقد أنه كان ، وبمجرد
رحيل الملكة ، فمن المحتمل أن تذهب
لأرغب في
التفكير مرة أخرى في الاستمرار مع king
charles
[موسيقى]
أولوية حكومتي هي
تأمين أفضل صفقة
ممكنة لأن البلد يغادر الاتحاد الأوروبي
جيدًا ، فأنا لا أقبل حقًا
فرضية  هناك واجب وتضحية في
أن تكون ملكًا ، لا أعتقد أن
طول العمر في المنصب هو أمر جيد في
المجتمع الديمقراطي كما تعلم أنه يجب
أن يكون لدينا الكثير من الفرص
لانتخاب رؤساء الدول كما يفعلون في
أماكن مثل أيرلندا أه  في آيسلندا وفنلندا ، كان من
الممكن أن يكون الأمر أكثر
إثارة للإعجاب وأكثر إلهامًا ولكن
بدلاً من ذلك كان لدينا نفس الشخص ليس
لأننا اخترناها ولكن
لأننا قيل لنا أن هذا
هو الحال بالنسبة لبقية
حياتها ولا أعتقد أن هذا
بالضرورة شيء يجب أن
نحتفل به